hello everyone
and welcome to rational science
directly from frankfurt germany
and what do we do here well we're the
only site on the internet that does
physics everybody else what do they do
well they do what they learn in
mathematical
physics which which is not really
physics
they have all these irrational
explanations such as
black holes big bang dark matter
dark energy and that's only on the
the big scale on the small scale is even
worse
particle can be at two places at once
they have all
irrational physical interpretations for
even the most common of phenomena
and of course they cannot explain
gravity what do we do here well
here uh we say that all atoms in the
universe
are interconnected physically
interconnected
if they're interconnected then there is
no real
action at a distance we see the things
that are made of atoms
and not the mediators that interconnect
them
meaning you know the um we can't see or
touch them
so there is no real action at a distance
mother nature does not work with spirits
from one atom to the next which is the
way
uh mathematical physics does it quantum
mechanics etc
anyways uh as always we're going to
divide
our lecture today or our show today
really in three parts
first part we're gonna do a little bit
of extinction i think that's worked
quite well second part i'm gonna do the
uh
a lecture on physics today we have we
have the quantum
dot whoa and then finally i'm going to
answer questions of those
folks who paid attention and asked
questions
even if those questions try to beat me
down
you know anyone can throw uh rotten
tomatoes at me no problem
i've got very thick skin
okay let's get on with it uh let's do a
little bit of extinction i start with a
little question
okay are we the last humans on earth the
last generation of humans on earth
and what i see around me does not look
very
promising and let me give you here for
instance here's my uh
dear friend and countryman pope frankie
and there was an article this week says
uh private
where he says right private property is
a secondary right
and that must have ticked off all the uh
rich folk all the conservatives that
support him
what do you mean private property is a
secondary right
and he says the right to property it is
a natural right but
secondary derived from the right that
everyone has
which is born of the universal destiny
of created goods
aha so we're all entitled to
something god-given i guess you know
because here you have the representative
of god himself telling us okay
the social disasters caused by pandemic
which has lasted for 15 months
leave too many unemployed and degrading
jobs for which
a deep reform of the economy and
essentially human work
are necessary and he said that the
current job
uh for so many uh changing workers for
the migrant and the precarious
but especially for so many women to
begin with domestic workers and street
vendors
is dangerous dirty and degrading
so if you do any of your those jobs
you know where you stand with a pope
okay and yeah
this comes at the heels of the pope uh
saying something about
also homosexuals uh a few months back i
think couple months back
and that didn't set well with the
conservatives either
uh he was saying essentially that um
you know we should accept them in the
catholic church
and partly part of the problem is that
catholic church like so many other
churches today
they're losing um customers
they're they're losing people you know
everywhere
and uh in fact uh recently we had the
southern baptists and they had a
little bit of a rift and then there
apparently there's gonna be
a breakup of the southern baptist uh
congregation and and again they're like
14 million strong they've been dropping
all these years
these last few years and now they might
even have a
split a schism like catholic church with
the
protestants in uh the 1600s right
uh 16th century so you know uh
you got to look at this you got to find
out you know
if if the church is breaking up and uh
church and i mean all churches for that
matter
and or and they're losing customers what
effect does that have
on uh you know on our notion of morality
family etc things that have been
the traditionally the the foundation
of society okay we're getting into a
world where we go with
individuals okay and
family is dying family belongs to the
days of
manufacturing services
that's a uh an individualistic society
and i think this is what they're trying
to do they're trying to see if they can
rescue some of the good things that
the catholic church has done of course
uh i'm sure
people can remember all the bad things
that the church did as well
and uh so let's pile up on on top of
this uh
here the fact that the chinese empire is
expanding
okay and this is making making the
united states very nervous
okay you can see what happened in 1980
2000
2020 how the
how the chinese are muslining in on the
u.s
empire okay the red zones
are where the united states used to have
a little bit of influence but now that
influence has been taken over by china
in other words china is buying them out
essentially you know they have
money now they're spreading it around
meanwhile the united states is having
problem economic problems trying to get
people back to work
so there's a little bit of difference
between what
the status of china today in in the us
okay and um now pile up on top of this
uh what happened this week here you have
um
mr putin and he met with uh
mr biden and this is what
mr putin said after um after the show
right after their talks says there's no
happiness
in life there's only a mirage on the
horizon
putin called the talks productive but
laid blame for the adversarial u.s
russia relationship
squarely on the u.s okay
so uh it's interesting that he would say
there's no happiness in life
you know i i took a college course uh
macroeconomics
and the instructor the first day came in
and he gave a little introduction
and then he said in this course
i'm going to define happiness as
money if you have money
you have happiness and of course this
was a
course dealing with money right and so
the question is uh mr poutine maybe
doesn't have money is that his problem
but i'm sure a lot of you people out
there you know you would say well yeah
you more or less agree with that that
you know it's
money that runs the world and of course
if you had a lot of money
man a lot of your problems would be
solved wouldn't they
so in that sense i guess you could say
yeah money is maybe a synonym
of happiness and the question is what
happens when we don't believe in money
anymore
uh will happiness disappear will there
be no more love
[Laughter]
in the last generation is love dying
i mean you know it used to be uh
families
they used to have kids uh we can't say
they were all happy of course not but
i guess between church and state and
custom and law and whatever they managed
to keep
everybody going you know and today a lot
of that is breaking up
and uh yeah everybody has what love for
maybe
two three four years maybe even less and
then they find new love and then another
new love and another new love
um is love dying
you know it does the last generation end
up with love
food for thought okay another fellow
says along these lines uh with poutine
and uh and um
biden says no bombs are fake
hiroshima was uh reopened the next day
they open up shop no problem chernobyl
in uh
nevada are safe with no unusual
radiation
well yeah otherwise you'd have to worry
about going to those casinos you know
maybe you should hit it instead with the
indian reservations they all have
casinos and maybe they don't have as
much
radiation as nevada
believing believing in nuke bombs is a
religion
believing in new bombs is not rational
well uh believing is not part of
rationality believing
has nothing to do with uh rationality
what we do in science that we say we
make assumptions
to explain something and you can begin
you know with an assumption saying let
us assume that nukes exist
now have you ever seen one of these
icbms under
silos underneath the ground uh have you
seen the
person pressing the button other than in
movies right
have you seen the person pressing the
button uh
to test it out or or where the whole
control room is
etc etc not only in the us but have you
seen them in russia
and china and maybe even uh what is it
north korea
uh yeah i mean you know um it all
depends on
what you believe in okay but
uh to think that we did not throw some
nukes that
uh you know that we went to the oceans
out there you know pacific ocean
and uh just threw a bomb to test it out
and then other people threw them
underground you know to say that
you don't believe that because you
weren't there you didn't see it
well it's more or less like the flat
earthers saying that you know
humans never went let alone to the moon
never went to space
you know uh yeah you can take it as far
as you want
uh it's more than uh
uh more than lack of belief it's it's
quite a ratio
okay yeah we we have learned how to
manage
uh nuclear
explosions manage we we know how to
build them but
whether we can manage them or not well i
don't think so
managing is simply you know right now by
treaty and it's uh
you know trust but verify that's about
it but you know if things
uh fall apart around the world i think
they will be
pressing the buttons part of that issue
will be
economics and i think that's the issue
the next issue by this while he says
war is about resources
yeah i kind of agree uh war
like i explained the other day is has
usually has always been done for
really for resources even when there
were
issues such as um
you know religious issues even those
were done for resources for expansion of
the empire
and it was one empire against another
empire that's all it was
and so what were they after well they
were after resources maybe
compelled the other side to pay tribute
or maybe because of access to
shipping lanes and commercial shipping
lanes and so on
and so yeah it's always been about
resources economics
war is founded on economics that's at
least the uh
assumption i make when i deal with
issues related to war
okay uh related to last week a
person says here what idiots think we
are not animals
as a species of life we need to eat
drink and have sufficiently socially
diversified
sex to reproduce efficiently as
long as those preconditions are met this
present species will go on
okay yeah and uh i think the
first two that you mentioned there eat
and drink that's where we're gonna have
a little bit of problems
that's what mass extinction is all about
but he says who would who would even say
this who would even think that we are
not animals
well someone responds and he says
we are classified as mammals but there
is so much that separates humans from
the animal kingdom
uh-huh well i think this fella has to
define the word animal scientifically in
a way that we can use it consistently
rationally right and so all he's got to
do is define the word
animal once we know what an animal is
for the purposes of science
right then we can use this word
consistently
in any dissertation okay so
uh you know all he's got to do is define
the word
then we'll know if a human is an animal
or not and he can't just go back and
forth and say
well um for the purpose of science he's
an animal
when we talk in our religion and our
congregation
you know at our club or our belief club
then we're going to treat man as
separate from the animals
but yeah you can do that in religion not
in science in science you got to be
consistent with the word
you're either an animal or you're not
and it's black or white on and off
on or off yes or no there's no
gray there you know you're either part
of the animal kingdom of you're not
or you're not if you're part of the
animal kingdom hey you got to
proceed with that definition so that
people can follow your train of thought
to say that we're animals but but no
we're not
or we're different or any qualifier that
you put in there
well then you know you you've got you're
only trying to protect some religion
that
deep-seated religion that you have
okay there was an article
on climate change this week and this has
to do again with
whether we're the last humans on earth
because we have all these
issues out there you got to be you know
in touch with says from burgers to
chocolate to beer
oh my god how climate change will affect
what we eat
remember the theory is eating we're
going to stop eating we're going to stop
eating because there will be no food
that's why we'll stop eating not because
we want to stop eating
as one guy says out there no it's going
to be because we're going to run out of
food
anyways the the article said the
continued buildup of greenhouse gases
in the atmosphere could imperil nearly
one third of global food crop production
and over one-third of livestock
production
by 2081 to 2100.
i cannot even imagine us reaching 2081.
i think we're going to uh disappear much
sooner than that you know some
some people those small pockets that
might survive
you know they might reach some age like
that i don't i'm not even sure they
they would reach that far but i think
they would
disappear quite earlier than that maybe
by 2050
2060 something like that but this fella
says
or or this the guy who wrote this
says uh by 2081 to 2100 in that
in that 21 20-year period livestock
production and crop
production will be reduced by one-third
and he says there is hope however if the
world's nations are as successful
in their goal of limiting global mean
temperatures it's about climate change
right
to warming between 1.5 and 2 degrees c
the impact on food production will be
lessened
and the next thing he does
this comes from a report that was uh an
article that was published
i think uh some norwegians or oh finnish
uh published this uh article in uh in a
peer-reviewed journal
and this guy just condensed it okay and
he says that
what will disappear or what is likely to
be reduced because of climate change our
graves meaning
he did an analysis for wine and i don't
want anyone touching wine please
i'll die without wine and uh says that
party might go down as well and that's
beer oh my god they're hitting all my
weak spots wine beer chocolate i love
chocolate coffee
i can't live without coffee i can't live
without these things these guys are
saying that
this is on its way out slowly
dying because they say they will not be
able to
produce the the plants needed to
uh maintain these markets and part of
that or a great part of that will be
climate change the climate will not
allow the
these uh plants to grow in the regions
where they're growing today
that's essentially what what they're
saying okay
and um so but but that
it didn't stop there they went ahead and
they talked about
uh certain other crops like saying
maybe corn and wheat which are very
important in the world might
have problems and they also talked about
some of the nuts
that you know some of the trees that
especially in california they have the
the
certain nuts that might have to be grown
in oregon or
washington state you know but this was
the issue the issue is they went into
cows they said meat meat and dairy
production accounts for
14 of annual greenhouse gas emissions
deforestation creates grazing land for
livestock
the intergovernmental panel on climate
change declared that
the prospect of eating less meat could
present
major opportunities for adaptation and
mediation
while generating significant co-benefits
in terms of human health and they're
proposing that
maybe insect protein might replace
meat for humans i'm wondering uh
is is this about uh getting everybody to
be a vegetarian or a vegan
is that what this is all about i mean is
this just
propaganda some uh you know to
to um enhance this
climate change issue that is so popular
these days now
i'm going to give you my two cents worth
uh climate change there's always been
climate change ever since uh the
cambrian we've had 542 million years of
climate change
there's been climate changes throughout
history in fact i don't think the earth
maintained a single climate ever
now the that's not the issue the issue
is the climate that we have right now we
have it for
the crops that we grow right now and if
the
climate happens to change significantly
whatever that means
right uh what does that mean
does that mean that we have to change
crops or maybe
plant them in the north pole somewhere
or you know what does it mean what does
it entail
can we feed eight or nine billion people
if there's a climate change okay so
that's the issue
and um you know i think there's always
been climate change but
i i this is my again my ten cents worth
two cents worth maybe one cent worth
uh climate change is totally irrelevant
totally irrelevant uh people who talk
about climate change have nothing better
to do
or don't understand extinction
and here again we're talking about
extinction i'm saying that
climate change is unrelated to
extinction in
any way shape or form had nothing at all
what to do with it
in any age in any era in the past eon
never did climate change destroy a
single peak species that wasn't the
cause
okay that's my 10 cents worth the cause
for mass extinctions
was food did food
disappear because of climate change
like you know the mass extinctions or
division
permian triassic and so on
is that what happened was there a
climate change and that
triggered the plants to die absolutely
not absolutely not the plants
died because they their cycle ran out
okay their cycle ran out they became
old they lost their genetic diversity
there was an
overturning of their population pyramid
and the animals that depended on them
when they couldn't find
any more of the food that they were had
when they and their ancestors had eaten
for millions of years
that's when it came to an end climate
change had nothing to do with it
if anything climate change helps the
next generation
when the new species of plants are
radiating
because the old species are dying then
yes
climate does change help one over
another so
i say that climate change has something
to do not only with the plants but with
the animals that rely on those plants
uh and where they are on the planet so
if uh maybe you know an animal makes the
most of the fact that there's
heat wherever he is maybe he's close to
the equator
he's gonna grow big and the other guy
who can't take it as much he's
gonna move to more temperate areas or
maybe the cold areas
and so you end up you know with a polar
bear
all white up north and you end up with a
grizzly what in
wyoming or whatever so you know i think
that's the way
it's done by mother nature essentially
what
what happens is that climate only
again it's an idea it's a proposal i'm
saying that climate only helps
uh the radiation that comes right after
uh mass extinction okay so that's my 10
cents worth on climate change
i think people should forget about it's
not an issue
a moot issue totally irrelevant okay
at least as far as extinction is
concerned climate change even if it
uh changes by i don't know five degrees
in this next century it's going to go so
slow
our economy is going to die a lot sooner
than
climate change ever happens okay
uh here's the next uh issue and again
along the same lines are we the
last humans on earth here we have these
ransomware attacks
and this is in parallel with all the
killings that are going on
especially in the united states i mean
there's a mass killing every
every day it's no longer news it's old
you don't know if you read the same
article or was it yesterday or was it
today because it's just one guy going
out there and killing
10 people or or whatever and here we
have these other fellas they do some
ransomware attacks
using what bitcoin as
uh the way to siphon the money out
and there's a company colonial shut down
100 million
gallon a day pipeline operations they
were providing to the east okay
which led to nearly a week of widespread
fuel shortages along the east coast
and the department of justice ultimately
recovered 2.3 million of the 4.4 million
what cryptocurrency ransom that colonial
paid to the group
darkseid man i should like to
be part of darkseid the dark
side and other companies
hit with these attacks include jbs a
meat supplier cna financial and
insurance company
mcdonald's the hamburger place oh my god
hospitals transportation providers and
even the
teamsters and this was after jimmy hoffa
after they got rid of him okay so uh
you know i don't know you tell me you
think um
we're having a little bit of problem
with uh the world
or is this business as usual has there
always been problems
uh in the last thousand years at least
uh of this nature
where there's always been crooks but
you know jesse james had to rob a bank
and these guys are not robbing banks
what they're doing is using
cryptocurrency they're
they're stealing uh money uh
through the internet you know just by
pulling out information from a company
and then saying hey
if you want it back we want a million
bucks
now how's that for robbing and stealing
so um we've got new kinds of crimes
going on
and a lot of that has to do with
cryptocurrency
which happened to fall quite a bit uh
these last couple weeks right
uh is that uh part of the
uh demise of money
this cryptocurrency is this part of our
the death of happiness
money is going to disappear in great
measure because
uh maybe some game that we play with
cryptocurrency
uh runs out of uh out of hand or maybe
everybody
goes into cryptocurrency more and more
and more and well that's a problem for
collecting taxes
on the one hand could be regulated i
guess
uh but is that part of the equation the
last
type of money that we'll ever have would
be cryptocurrency
or can you invent a new type of currency
that we will use
in the next million years
okay anyways food for thought i always
want to say this that you should
do extinction 101 before 102 if you want
to talk about extinction
what is 101 it's mass extinction first
you got to show that you're an
expert on mass extinction and then you
can talk about extinction 102 which is
human
extinction okay so and the reason i put
it in those terms is that
you need to understand a mass extinction
well and understand all the issues there
what died in the past
during mass extinctions and then somehow
extrapolate that to man and find out if
man can
overcome the same mechanism the same
factors that kill the animals in the
past
that's that's my take on that and then
of course
uh that's related to this the uh
question that i put in tandem with that
and that's the homework and
why did the founder indices disappear at
the same time
more or less right as the animals on
land
if you can explain that well maybe you
have a
valid theory for the extinction of man
and you know the option is what uh to
say that man will never disappear
we will live forever
that's what the religious folk
traditional religions have been saying
at least for the last two thousand years
you will live forever
okay once you die your soul
goes to heaven right and that's what a
lot of these people believe
okay let's get on with the uh lecture
today
physics what's that got to do with
what's got to do with this uh quantum
dot
what the hell is a quantum dot is is
that something like the
geogra geometric point
is that what that's all about i mean
here's the geometric point is
is that what the quantum dot is after
all you know
whenever someone says um in geometry
mathematics whatever right they say uh
what is a point and they take the pen
you know
and they hit the paper or they
hit the chalk on the board or maybe a
crayon against
uh you know a piece of carton there
you know and they'll say that's a dot
well there you see a dot is that the
point and the point is a dot
well there is a difference you see
because the point geometric
point as we've covered it recently right
is zero dimensional it's zero size no
radius no nothing
that's what the point is what is point
it's a location
is that what a dot is a quantum dot
right is that what a quantum dot
is it's just a location
i mean they're talking about quantum
right and we've covered it this week
uh the quantum dot uh apparently
according to the definitions that are
out there are greater than zero size
but the quantum particles like the point
particles
you know uh electron gluon quark
those are all zero dimensional zero
nothing fact they're not even
particles what they are is wave function
collapses
whatever that means to you you have an
equation that collapses
a probability or i don't know i i can't
even picture it
and you can't it's nothing it's a zero
dimensional no
size nothing and they do use the word
infinitesimal in these situations you
know they like to use the word
infinitesimal
because it gives you the idea that well
no it's not
truly point particle it's not zero
dimensional
it's just infinitesimally small
what does that mean well that means it's
approaching zero in size
approaching is not zero in other words
approaching zero
is not zero exactly zero there's a
difference
approaching zero means it still has size
but they use the
word infinitesimal which is very
extremely misleading
and why do they do that well they want
to give you the idea
that it's an observer related issue that
you can't really see it very well
no kid yeah you can't see an atom very
well except
like from a uh telescopic uh
[Music]
uh view you know uh like an eagle would
see it you know from
from far away we can see atoms like that
we have
image atoms like that with atomic force
microscopes and so on
but to see an atom up front like one
atom with all the little electrons
rolling around
uh never seen that never filmed that
never
been able to image that and
because we can't get closer we don't
have the resolution to see that
okay so the question is the uh quantum
dot
the same thing as the geometric point
and the answer is no because the
geometric point as well as the quantum
point particles they're all zero
dimensional they're
you could say non-dimensional because
they're really talking about concepts
weight function collapse what the hell
is that that's not a physical object
on the other hand the quantum dot is
used in technology
and so and they don't claim for it to be
zero size
so one of the issues you got to think
about today why do they put the
adjective quantum why do they call it
quantum dot
if it's uh it could be a dot but
certainly not quantum quantum has to do
with i mean this could be a classical
dot
but not a quantum dot quantum mechanics
is
understandable you can't understand
you cannot explain quantum mechanics and
here the the dot as you're going to see
we're going to be able to explain the
classical part but we're not going to be
able to explain
is the quantum part okay so let's move
on here
so what is a quantum dot here it is okay
here's your quantum dot it looks
something like that
quantum dots nano crystals 2 to 10
nanometers
in diameter nanometer is uh you know um
you get a centimeter millimeters you get
smaller and smaller to micrometers and
finally at
uh the ninth decimal point you get the
uh
nanometer so it's a very small uh uh
thing anywhere from two to ten
nanometers in diameter
okay so what are we talking about that
but this is not zero size
obviously okay and so they're saying
we got something there okay at least
it's defined that way
and they're nano crystals so we're
talking about crystals
meaning that the crystal is made of many
many atoms not to mention molecules so
so you know you're talking about
something very small but it is made of
atoms
okay when exposed to light uh quantum
dots emit light for uh of particular
frequencies
okay so you have you know the wavelength
and
different wavelengths have different
colors and you can also say that
different frequencies have different
colors
because according to the equation
velocity of light c
right equals to what frequency times
wavelength one goes up the other one has
to go down they're inversely
proportional
so when you increase the frequency the
wavelength goes down and vice versa
and you know high frequencies
uh long wavelengths are
you know identified with low end of the
spectrum reddish i mean for the visible
light
and the um
did i say that high frequency is the
blue
where its low frequency is the reddish
end
and vice versa for the wavelength
wavelength if it's long it's reddish and
if it's short
it's bluish okay so that's essentially
what the spectrum looks like and what
these people say is that
when exposed to light these quantum dots
emit light of a particular frequency
okay so we have the electromagnetic
wavelength you know which is color
a measure of color right mathematical
measure of color
is emitted and it's dependent on the
particle size you're going to say so it
depends on
how big this quantum dot is
the higher it is it's got a different
color than if it's
low size okay so big size low size
it changes the wave length okay
and it's also precise control of size
and what shape so they're talking about
size and shape
okay and the way they do that is
adjusting reaction time and conditions
but we're not interested in the
technology we don't do technology here
we're not interested in that at all
we want to know what is the uh
mechanism that they're going to use to
explain
what's going on in that micro world
subatomic world or even an atomic world
if if there is like you know interaction
between atoms we're interested in that
as well
right okay so first of all here again a
little more technology how they build
these things or
how they make them quantum dots are nano
crystals again they're crystals
meaning they're made out of many
molecules or many atoms okay
made by combining metals such as lead
and or
cadmium with other elements including
sulfur selenium
and arsenic and there on the bottom you
have cadmium
cell selenide okay that's one of the
compounds that
which they make these dots okay by
controlling the
ratio of these starting materials the
temperature and the reaction time
scientists can generate a nearly
unlimited number of dots
with differences in an electronic
property known as
band gap and we'll explain that in a
second which determines the wavelengths
of light
that each dot will absorb
and my first issue is what are they
called scientists what's this got to do
with science
i mean these people are technologists if
uh if that's what they're doing they're
developing
you know uh crystals what's what's
scientific about that
that's like going to the patent office
and say look i built this little crystal
and i did it by uh putting all these
molecules together and building up this
little ball of
crystal crystal ball right
that's technology what's that got to do
with science with
explaining the mechanism of how
one of these things works why
does wavelength have to do with the size
and shape
of these nanoparticles that's what we
would like to know
that's what we would like to understand
that's what we would like for someone to
explain and they don't do that okay so
this is
this is where we have a little bit of
problem with these folks
okay uh here's a
an illustration of what they just said
you have light coming in and they built
these little balls
that have all these little layers okay
of um of molecules these are the
so-called crystals okay and this is what
they're
this is in general terms how it's going
to work okay they're just going to build
these things
and again we don't care about the
technology we don't care how they're
built we don't care what
chemical element they use specifically
not so important we want to know the
mechanism
okay so what is it the mac what is the
mechanism that these people
are going to talk about that are going
to explain well here's one okay
so the quantum physical interpretation
okay under the influence of light
electrons are excited okay whoa
they're excited and quantum jump up to a
higher energy band
whatever that is okay we'll find out in
a second electrons can also fall back to
a lower energy state
or recombine and re-radiate
okay so this is how they're gonna play
around with that okay so what do they
mean an
electron is going to go up and the
electron is going to go down what the
hell are these people talking about
okay here we have an idea okay
a little more detail a band gap what is
that
well you have two things you have the
conduction of the
let's start at the other you have the
valence band which is the outer layer
of an atom used to be at least in my
days
but uh from there it move the electron
can move to
the conduction band and the question is
whether the conduction band is part of
the atom
or part of the flow of current
i mean does the electron stay in the
conduction band and
keeps whizzing around the the atom or
does it fly away
okay so this is important because they
talk about the electron
jumping up because you know you hit it
with energy
you hit it with this uh photon this
ball of light it imparts
energy to the electron the electron now
moves from the
valence band outer electron outer
orbital of an atom
this is the outermost orbital and it's
going to move it into the conduction
band
whatever that is what is the convection
band does that mean that now the
we have a higher level of
energy there that the electron continues
rolling around the atom
in the conduction band or does it fly
away and become
become part of another atom does it flow
uh you know electrical flow is what the
flow of electron beads right so
what happens to that electron okay does
it stay there
well it says the band gap which is the
difference in energy levels
mathematics nothing to do with physics
this is just an accounting procedure
here
between the top of the valence band and
the bottom of the conduction band
determines the wavelength of the emitted
light
okay so you can see that there's a
difference the
energy that so-called energy which is
what it's
it's light coming in it's a photon why
they draw it as a wave i have no idea
because i thought the
the photon you know when it hits
the surface in this case it hits an
electron
very good um uh
accuracy it just hits it right i mean
electron b
we can't even measure its pinpoints
nothing right and here we have a photon
which is another nothing and this
nothing hits this other nothing
bumps it off into a higher into the
conduction band or a higher energy level
okay that's that's the explanation
that's what their
this is their physical interpretation
and uh
here's a little uh gif on this uh
showing you you know the differences in
an insulator
the band gap is too big too large
and so it's very hard to knock an
electron
from the outer valence level
to the conduction band segment conductor
a little easier
how about conductor well conductor
essentially the
conductor the valence band and the
conduction band are one in the same
okay so they're either like iron iron is
has conductor uh and valence
bands are the same and here you can see
it yeah you know you see how
with a little bit of energy you knock
electrons from the valence band into the
conduction band
and now they're going to start flowing
okay you'll see this in a second here it
is
and you can see the electrodes are
flowing so they don't stay in like in a
conduction band
around an atom they start flowing
they start flowing and that's what we
call electricity
you know the flow of electron beads
and you say well what's wrong with all
this bill it looks like
a sound theory you know one would think
it's
it's okay you say look you got a little
bead
it's going around the um outer shell
obviously because we're only talking
about the valence band
the outer shell of an atom okay
irrespective of what atom it is it's the
outer shell
you hit it with a little bit of energy
meaning a photon meaning a wave
whatever that is you knock it into the
conduction band
okay so now this little bead is in the
conduction band now it's going to flow
along the conduction band
and that conduction band is what we call
electricity
nothing wrong with that but what happens
because the difference in
between the conduction band and the uh
valence band
it depends on what that distance is well
you have different colors of light
because the color of light is dependent
the
wavelength frequency if you will
uh is dependent on that distance okay
and for conductors obviously that's uh
much easier because there's one
conductor and valence band are one in
the same
essentially okay where did we get all
this nonsense from well we got it from
from this these are the notions that we
have of the atom
it's the planetary atom that you see and
these are two different
atoms that i found on the internet and
they essentially put the same thing
everybody's using the planetary model
to explain this and so what is the
planetary model
well as you can see there it's um it's
got these circles
and those are the energy bands
okay those are the orbitals
meaning that it is an orbital in orbit
uh not quite it's uh it's like an orbit
but it's a region within which you can
find
the electron orbiting okay
that's the best way to explain it and
that's what you're seeing you're seeing
a cross-section in other words a
two-dimensional
uh vision of what an orbital is you're
supposed to see this or imagine it
visualize it
as a shell okay but the shell what is
the shell the shell
is the um
orbital and the orbital you
think of in orbit because you see the
beads going around
actually no because the beat is one
thing and the orbital is another the
orbital is
where the electron is trapped within
okay so the electron is trapped within
the orbital we cannot leave the prison
okay and it can move around
in a region with within the orbital but
it cannot
uh fall to the lower orbital
every electrons out there in his own
orbital okay and again we have zero
dimensional electrons in their own
orbitals okay so these are the physical
interpretation
and where do we get this nonsense well
we get it from these two gentlemen
and this one is bore and the other one
is rutherford this is where the
planetary model came
uh bohr in what was in 1911 he came up
with the
orbitals the notion that an electron can
fall from one energy level to another
and back
up and when it does it emits a given
frequency of light or a
given wavelength of light so that's
where this quantum dot got the idea
you know that electron is a bead that
just falls from one
energy level to the next up and down and
when it does it emits
light and the frequency or wavelength of
that light is dependent on
that gap on that distance between energy
levels
what did rutherford come up with in 1919
actually he finally inferred it a few
years later
but he said look this is the nucleus and
the nucleus is the center of the atom
and
at the time he was thinking of maybe
just a single proton in there
but here you have protons and neutrons
which
uh came a little later chadwick came up
with that idea james chadwick
of the neutron and so one came up with a
nucleus and the other guy came up with
the orbitals and they put them together
and that's the
planetary model that we have today that
everybody uses to explain
among other things the quantum dot
okay because what is it that we have to
explain about the quantum dot
well we have to explain the wavelength
why
uh this quantum dot emits different
colors
okay why when you build it when you make
this technology
whether for screens or whatever you're
going to use them for
why it is able to emit
and remember it's not reflecting it's
really emitting different wavelengths
meaning different colors okay that's
what it does that's that's the value
of it technology hey
love it uh science where is it
we don't have any science yet okay we
don't have any explanation
and you say well why don't we have an
explanation well here here is the
the problem here's the main problem that
these people have to explain
in a nutshell the first one is why
doesn't the electron
fall to a lower energy level to
automatically why does it continue
falling all the way down in fact to the
proton
isn't the electron negative whatever
that is isn't the proton positive
whatever that is
in physical terms if we have negative
and positive
uh i thought that negative attracted
positive positive attracts negative
why doesn't the electron fall to the
center of the nucleus where you have all
these positive charges known as protons
i mean it's a very simple question why
does it fall in there they never
answered that question
which was one of the reasons they came
up with a planetary model
and what did bohr answer well he said it
is so he took his uh
uh magic wand which i don't have here
for a second huh
took his magic wand and he says it is so
and he was able to explain the spectrum
of hydrogen
because of this but yeah i mean
mathematically
but you still have not explained the
physical process the mechanism
and so i mean why doesn't the electron
fall to the proton then you have the
other issue
why didn't the electron go outside of
the orbital why does it fly away
so you have these two situations why
does the electron
stay within a given band energy band
energy gap whatever you want to call it
i don't care orbital
uh why does it stay in that in that lane
why why doesn't it go outside the lane
you know get an ice cream cone
before it continues running okay so
it doesn't fall out of the energy band
orbital whatever you want to call it it
doesn't fall inwards to the proton
or nucleus why
what's what's preventing those two
situations from happening that's what we
don't have an answer to
today and they never will they'll never
will why
because you cannot explain it with
particles with discrete particles
that's where the problem is now uh
here we can explain it
maybe by showing a construction
okay of uh
our version of that atom and maybe i
should put
them side by side here's our uh
uh atom uh here's let's see where was
this
yeah here's the other one let me put
this one over here
and this one over here so this is their
model
okay the planetary model and you can see
our model the one we're proposing in
exchange and why
uh we are able to explain these things
such as quantum junk
and why we have certain frequency and
wavelength
because you know every atom in the
universe is bound by
what we call the electromagnetic rope
binds any two atoms
there you see the construction of the
atom on the bottom right
okay and uh one thread of the rope
forms the electron shell which is uh
encapsulating the proton star which is
made by
arbitrarily the electric thread okay
and so the the rope becomes an atom and
the atom becomes a rope and so on down
the line
forever now we can explain why when the
atom expands and contracts
it uh emits light frequency
wavelength y because it's uh the link of
a rope
see they cannot explain that they cannot
explain why the atom doesn't fall to the
center of the atom we can because see
the balloon just expands and contracts
there is no the balloon does not
collapse completely to the
center of the atom because it's got all
these uh
i call them uh i mean you can think of
it as a
rolled up urchin sea urchin all the or
maybe
uh a porcupine you know the
all the quills are pointing outwards and
so the
shell can only go so far back and forth
and what it does it just pumps back and
forth
okay so it cannot collapse the electron
shell
all the way to the center of the atom
and when these people are talking about
an electron bead what they're looking at
is one of the
points a location on the electron shell
that's what an electron has been all
these hundreds this hundred years these
past hundred years
okay so you can see there's a difference
but see we can explain action at a
distance with this
which is one thing that the quantum
model will never be able to explain
how does this particle over here
influence that particle over there
how do you do that this is the issue and
you cannot explain that that's why they
cannot explain gravity
gravity they know they realize
intuitively it's a pull
force of some kind how do you pull with
particles
okay you got two particles okay uh
here okay how does particle pull on that
one
now if they're connected you know
by something you can't see or touch
now we can see why you know uh i mean at
least you can
now imagine pull okay because uh
that there is a mediator the only issues
that we cannot see or touch that
mediator
and so there is no real action at a
distance just we can't see or touch it
okay okay um what can we conclude from
this well here here's the conclusions
that i reached
the quantum dot is infinitesimally small
okay
why do they use infinitesimally why do
they talk about
two nanometers to two to ten nanometers
well they want to
give you the idea that you can't really
see them they're little crystals so tiny
you can't see them so they're
infinitesimally small and they don't
worry about the problem anymore because
mathematicians so-called scientists
they don't care about architectures
shape
they don't care about size okay meaning
something greater than zero and that's
sense size
and so they use the word infinitesimal
to refer to these things why because the
observer cannot see it
now they do need shape and size because
on the one hand it's immaterial to them
but on the other hand
shape and size are what make the quantum
dot useful in technology
remember shape and size of the quantum
dot that's going to determine what
color wavelength it emits okay so
uh we're not interested in technology
we're not interested in that part we're
interested in
why does it and these people are saying
well it's related to shape and size
okay how is it related to shape and size
why
what causes shape and size to change
the wavelength or the frequency that's
what they have not
answered that's why they're not
scientists they're just technologists
people who
are developing stuff without seeing you
know they're blind
okay q a quantum explanation but is it
electron jumps from valence to
conduction band and back
yeah but see in order to do that they
need the irrational planetary atom
okay and so they say different sizes and
shapes of dots
mean different wavelengths yeah and why
why if they're going to use the
planetary atom they can only describe it
mathematically and say well this is what
happens
this is what we measured but they cannot
explain the process
with discrete particles okay so now
quantum dots are technology not science
and the fact that they use quantum the
adjective quantum
that they put that in front of it is
very misleading because people
approach you and you'll say well hold it
quantum is irrational blah blah blah
and they'll say well no but we have
quantum computers
and quantum dots
and they use that word quantum they
think they're talking about science you
say well
okay so we have quantum computers in
guantanamos you would have a computer if
it weren't
for quantum but see
they don't realize that computers are
classical
objects that we can see and touch
and manipulate etc it's what we're
trying to figure out
what happens at the uh genuinely
genuine quantum level in other words
what happens
at the atomic and subatomic level that's
where
that's where we're stuck that's where we
can't get an answer from them
so if the computer works it would be it
works because of transistors
not because of quantum quantum is
something else quantum
has all these weird explanation physical
interpretations for what happens at the
sub
atomic level at the level of light
or gravity which they cannot explain
okay that's where
that's where quantum uh that's where
quantum
really that's its realm not here not at
the classical level
and this so-called quantum dot is a
classical dot because
it's a crystal that has size and shape
none of the particles of quantum
mechanics has size or shape
if you don't believe me just go to
standard model and tell me
what an electron looks like do you see a
shape there in the standard model do
they have a nice little picture
especially when the swedes
i think uh university or they wrote a
paper
showing that they were able to film an
electron
good you filmed an electron you should
be able to give tell me what an atom
looks like
and what holds the electron to the atom
and you cannot say that the electron is
zero dimensional
point particle if you filmed it
okay so this is where the problem is
quantum dot does not belong to science
it belongs strictly
to technology and it should be called a
classical
dot
okay let's move on to the questions okay
here we have the first one
fellow says
says uh tubes of force this is faraday's
notion of
electricity uh the only problem is force
is a concept
and so uh what do we have two tubes of
love
tubes of intelligence
what is this what kind of tube is that
so yeah faraday could use any words he
wanted because he wasn't able to
visualize the
invisible intangible entity that was
mediating
for example magnetism he could not see
him
he could do experiments say oh you know
i can attract all these iron filings i
can do all these fancy things with
magnets
yeah those are the visible part that's
the classical part what about the
invisible
quantum part okay and you cannot use
terms like
tubes of force because uh
you either talk about tubes or above
force and if it's a tube of force you're
really talking about
force and force is a concept so yeah you
got a
good old uh faraday has to come back and
tell us what he meant by
force a two before sufficient
okay another question issue fellow says
we can't see touch or measure these
ropes
yeah okay but they are objects because
what they have shape yeah correct
irrational oh my god
okay let's find out if it's irrational
um what we got to do in science
is define okay we have to define what we
mean by
an object and so yeah it's easy to say
but hard to do
what what this all said you know c touch
can't be
used consistently and uh in other words
rationally uh it is irrational why
because you can see there just an
example i
gave a couple of times already uh you
can't see the
klingons uh table
he's on the other side of the universe
in a planet roaming around there
you can't see or touch it so
is his table an object
i mean according to the criteria if
we're going to use c and touch
we can't see her touching so yeah the
spell has to
define all he does is repeat himself all
the time
he's not he's not answering the question
he's running away with his tail between
his legs oh he's doing his religion he's
repeating over and over and over
oh it's c-touch it's c-type yeah tell me
why i mean
uh how can we use c-touch in this
context
if i can't see the uh china man's
table on the other side of this uh
planet
that means that his is not a table his
table is not an object because i
i can't see or touch it it's not an
object for me
it's an object maybe for him and maybe
when he's at work he can't see it either
so it's not an object for him
it becomes an object when he comes home
and he can see and touch it again
i mean you know what the hell is this
now you can't use this
c-touch criterion and
let me double up on that uh
uh here is uh a criteria for
irrationality because you said it's
irrational well
okay what do you mean by irrational
let's define irrational
see and we do define irrational uh
treating concepts as objects
okay reification compromisation uh
using inconsistent definitions or
undefined words which is what this file
is using so he
is irrational not us uh if he wants to
be rational uh
put a definition that you can use
consistently then you'll
you'll show us that you're rational and
again you got to define the word
rational or
irrational what are the two so that we
know what you mean when you say it's
irrational
you can't say the irrational is anyone
who doesn't agree with you
no that's not a very uh objective
definition now you have to define the
word irrational
if you're going to use it and yeah i
took the trouble defining all these
words because i knew those are the weak
points of mathematical physics
they have not defined object they have
not defined what exists means
and among other words they haven't
defined what irrational or rational
is or means uh they just say oh you're
irrational we're going to call you a
crackpot a crank
and they leave it at that no no maybe
you're the crank because you haven't
defined the word irrational and so we
don't know what you mean when you say
that i'm a crank i'm a rational
individual
it's the other way around okay theory
isn't consistent with or doesn't follow
from the assumption those are three main
ones and
what mathematicians do is they describe
instead of explaining they call it a
theory
not a theory a theory is an explanation
and then you have the
mechanism assumption doesn't work or
cannot even be imagined
okay and so uh yeah
those are the criteria for uh
for what we mean by irrational
if you don't like it no problem get on
uh
you know get your sword and shield get
in the ring
and defend your definition whatever
definition you have for both
object and for rationality or
irrationality
okay uh foul says
says the scientific method and he goes
through this
sequence he says make an observation ask
a question okay
form a hypothesis or testable
explanation is that what a hypothesis is
testable explanation i thought it was a
prediction a prediction is a description
and so you know an explanation is not a
prediction it's not a
description so no hypothesis is not a
testable
explanation they have so many
definitions for hypotheses that people
bunch them all up and say well all of
that is a
is a hypothesis no hypothesis is
an assumption and the assumption
includes the objects the
um definitions and the initial scene the
first few frames of the film that
set the framework for what you're going
to explain
now make a prediction test the
prediction how are you going to test the
prediction you go to the future i guess
and iterate use the results to make new
hypothesis
or predictions okay okay and
what do we put against this well we put
the
well here's a mathematical method
mathematical
method which is what he just explained
okay here's in a little more detail
i put this up the other day uh what he's
saying is you make an observation in
other words you gawk
okay you gawk observe something with
your dueling mouth wide open
then you have to gawk again okay repeat
the observation
then you prophecy okay you make a
prediction test your hunch with an
experiment which is what this guy says
you make a prediction you test the
prediction
okay uh measure calculate do some math
he didn't put that in there okay you got
to do all that stuff in
in the religious method or the
mathematical method okay
you propose the most ridiculous physical
interpretation you can imagine otherwise
it won't be accepted
by your peers yeah you get it because
otherwise if you propose something
rational they say what do you think you
are god
that you know it all so no you gotta
propose an
irrational explanation they'll believe
that when they say okay
maybe they'll believe it because it
doesn't compete against them
they say well we all have irrational
explanation yours is just a little more
irrational in mind
okay great maybe that's the criteria but
yeah you got to come up with the most
ridiculous
physical interpretation you can imagine
then you sell to your
peers okay high-priced individual and
ask them to give you a medal
and then you if you do get a medal then
you can censor and treat
us cranks and craft bucks all those who
are skeptical of your proven theory
okay that's the method that is used
today
and i guess that's the one this guy's
defending okay
and here's uh the real mathematical
uh i mean the real scientific method
against the mathematical method
okay side by side so you can see the
difference okay
the scientific method step one objects
definitions
in initial scene or first frames and
that's known as the assumptions or
hypothesis okay and then the theory is
based on that because
what are we gonna do we're gonna give
you a rational explanation
of a mechanism in physics okay and so
uh those are the primary two mechanisms
and causes okay so you can see there's a
difference between what this valve
proposes
and uh genuine scientific method
what do we need the scientific method
for well we needed to
explain a mechanism which we don't have
today we don't have explanations
efficiently
for gravity none at all uh they do have
one at the
macro level general relativity
uh and that one is essentially
essentially
irrational why why because they're
saying that space-time which is a
concept
bends and that's the notion that they
have
of gravity why does it bend well because
a force pushes the ball down
against space-time meaning they invoke
uh
good old newton which they say general
relativity does not rely on forces
you you figure it out and that's uh in
general relativity in quantum mechanics
they don't have
uh any explanation for the force of
gravity
and then other than that uh all the
other explanations are irrational you
know particle can be at two places at
once there are parallel universes
and whenever you know uh you don't peek
in the box
uh schrodinger's cat could be is not not
could be but
is in all universes simultaneously
um multiverse so
the cat goes off into all these
different places okay
simultaneously so in this universe the
cat died in that other one he's still
alive
the other one he's playing poker maybe
who knows
or it becomes garfield or a cartoon
character
okay so yeah uh the big problem we have
right now is that
this uh method that this fellow uh put
up there
it's it's not scientific at all because
all it
does is create descriptions and you know
maybe it's uh used for technology more
power to them
but that's not science that's technology
that's got to do with
gadgets the developing gadgets by trial
and error
it's got absolutely nothing to do with
science with explanations
of mechanisms and with that
i will see you on wednesday and so yeah
ask your question